this video is the first episode in my
upcoming series on the resurgence of
fascism around the world
since youtube has an awful content
flagging system and doesn't
differentiate between videos speaking
critically of things and those
advocating for them the rest of the
series will be exclusive to a new
platform called rockfin
you can get access to that series and
lots of other great radical content by
following the link below
[Music]
let's do a little word association i'm
going to give you three words and you
decide whether each word has a generally
good connotation or a bad one ready
patriotism good fascism
bad nationalism somewhere in the middle
this one depends on your perspective but
i'd guess about 60 or 70 percent of you
would say nationalism has a bad
connotation
while each of these three isms is
animated by pride in one's country
they exist on a spectrum of increasing
animosity towards others
enough pride in your own country could
very easily lead you to be frustrated
with the perspectives of other countries
and without even being aware of it
you've slipped from patriotism into
nationalism
enough frustration with other countries
often leads to bitterness distrust and
eventually to hatred
while your loyalty to your homeland only
increases that
fierce loyalty to your own country and
the animosity towards others is often
enough to bring about the rise of
fascism
the desire to bring the rest of the
world under the rule of the one truly
good nation
in this episode we're going to discuss
how patriotism is the gateway drug to
nationalism
and under some circumstances fascism
before we begin
let's take a second to define these
three terms so we're all on the same
page
we'll start with patriotism patriotism
is a love for
and devotion to one's country
nationalism expands on that adding
especially a sense of national
consciousness exalting one nation above
all others and placing primary emphasis
on promotion of its culture and
interests as opposed to those of other
nations
the distance between nationalism and
fascism is much larger
fascism is defined as a political
philosophy movement or regime that
exalts nation and often race above the
individual
and that stands for a centralized
autocratic government headed by a
dictatorial leader
severe economic and social regimentation
and forcible suppression of opposition
when placed on a spectrum it's easy to
see how someone could go from being a
patriot to a nationalist without ever
noticing the transition
it seems like it would be much more
difficult to reach the stage where
you're comfortable calling for
authoritarian measures and decrying the
inhumanity of different groups
but it's more common and far more
insidious than you might think
now before we go any further let me say
that this video is not
only about conservatives yes fascism is
a right-wing ideology
despite what some misguided
conservatives would have you believe but
it's also about maintaining dominance
over people who are deemed inferior
and no one is better at feeling superior
than the united states
our foreign policy is fascist whether a
democrat is in the white house or a
republican
it's only when those authoritarian
tendencies are brought home that the
average american begins to notice
this video is also not about the youtube
and 4chan radicalization pipeline
there have been plenty of videos on the
subject and i highly recommend this one
by innuendo studios if you're interested
i'll mention youtube eventually because
it's something i'm very familiar with
but i want to focus on the
radicalization of a group that's largely
ignored
our parents generation the people born
in the 60s and 70s who don't use the
internet as much as we do
and are therefore paradoxically more
isolated from and more vulnerable to
far-right propaganda
the generally decent people who consume
daytime tv and radio talk shows but who
probably have no idea
who joe rogan and jordan peterson are as
one final disclaimer before we begin
i want to address the conservative
talking point that's bound to come up in
the comments
the claim that leftists are actually the
fascists first of all the people making
these claims lump everyone from centrist
to communists into the same category
centrists and liberals are not the left
they have a lot more in common with
conservatives than either group would
care to admit
the claim that the left is fascist
hinges upon the fact that there are some
problems that are universally accepted
and that includes by both far-right
extremists and socialists like me
just about everybody regardless of
political opinions can agree that the
economy is in trouble and that the
average americans are being left behind
by the increasingly wealthy elite
but acknowledgment of a problem is very
different from agreeing on solutions
to the left the solutions would be at
the very least strengthening unions so
that american workers have more
bargaining power
and taxing the ultra wealthy at a much
higher rate to the far right the
solutions are expelling immigrants
jailing political dissidents and getting
rid of the jews who supposedly pull the
strings of the nation's banks and media
operations
only one of these sets of solutions is
fascist fascism can be pretty insidious
if you take nazi germany for example
hitler implemented modest social reform
policies that could be considered
left-wing
in america at least but those policies
came with the tiny little caveat that
they had to eradicate an entire culture
plus any gays and communists they could
catch for good measure fascism will
always come bundled with racist
xenophobic and violent ideology it's
part of the deal
with all those preliminary matters out
of the way let's meet our average
50-something suburban voter
her name is karen karen is a
stay-at-home mom probably has a designer
dog
drives a mid-sized bmw or mercedes suv
and hasn't had to apply for a job since
1985.
she watches fox news listens to
conservative talk radio and has no idea
that she's become a meme
when karen was growing up the news was
something you could watch in the morning
or in the evening
and there were many fewer channels to
choose from the era of 24-hour news
cycles and hundreds of channels wouldn't
begin until 1994.
during her formative years karen
witnessed the space shuttle challenger
disaster the wall street crash of 1987
and the end of the cold war she saw the
u.s take its place as the soul world
superpower and by the 90s
things had settled into a comfortable
lull for the united states
then in 1996 a media mogul named rupert
murdoch hired roger ailes to head up his
new project
fox news this selection was very
intentional
roger ailes had been active in both tv
and politics for decades
acting as an aide and advisor for both
the nixon and george h.w bush
administrations coaching them on
everything from what ties to where to
how to spin certain policies for the
media
ailes was a talented and devoted
propagandist and a master of media
manipulation
and he had big plans for injecting the
republican party into mainstream
american thought
years after his work constructing fox
news a 318-page trove of documents was
unearthed from the bowels of the bush
and nixon presidential libraries
this collection simply titled a plan for
putting the gop
on tv news dated back to the 1970s and
detailed ayles's plan to build a pro-gop
news operation to be run out of and
partially funded by the white house
even back then ailes understood the
potential for tv news
he said people are lazy with television
you just sit
watch listen the thinking is done for
you when he was brought on for fox news
ailes chose not to hire experienced
journalists
and instead constructed a team of
inexperienced partisans he could count
on to read his pro-gop scripts
ailes himself was rapidly homophobic
racist and completely without
journalistic integrity
together with rupert murdoch he built a
faux news media empire that today is the
most profitable in the country
in no small part thanks to murdoch's
massive investment to pay cable
providers to air their network
this was unheard of normally a cable
company would pay networks to license
their shows
fox news did the opposite buying their
way into 25 million homes
ailes praised murdoch's move saying this
is capitalism and one of the things that
made this country great
he was right about it being a pure
expression of capitalism but i think
most reasonable people would disagree
that being able to dominate the airwaves
simply by virtue of your extreme wealth
is a good thing
this is when the right-wing propaganda
machine really took off
the pro-war anti-union anti-regulation
party now had a dedicated state media
outlet
fox news immediately set to work
branding themselves and the republican
party as the ones looking out for
average americans
railing against the coastal elites and
intellectuals dressing themselves in
patriotic imagery and declaring
themselves defenders of freedom in the
face of creeping socialism
these weren't new talking points but
putting it on tv for 24 hours a day was
a new approach
and it worked the key was not only
selling themselves as the good guys
but casting everyone who was not them as
the bad guys people who were out to
steal your freedom and invade your
suburban oasis
they're not satisfied with spreading the
chaos and violence
into our communities they want to
abolish the suburbs altogether
this forestry zoning would bring crime
lawlessness
and low quality apartments into now
thriving suburban neighborhoods
fox knew their market nervous housewives
the uneducated and the elderly
and that's not to say that fox news
viewers are stupid it's an indictment on
a predatory propaganda network that uses
fear as a motivating tactic
fox picked out the demographics that
identified as proud americans and set to
work trying to convince these people
that the others were coming to destroy
everything that makes our country great
in this way patriotism the love and
support for one's country was twisted
into a defensive position instead of a
passive feeling
democrats are trying to ban christmas
buy our american flag blankets to show
them real patriots aren't afraid
and on and on but this doesn't explain
how self-proclaimed patriots become
nationalists
sure their patriotism has become warped
and reactionary but what causes the
transformation
long story short time and the
exploitation of traumatic events
fox news has only been around for about
24 years a lot of people my age can
remember a time when their parents
seemed less
scared less xenophobic that's not just a
natural change
that comes from them living in a time
before fox news and then suddenly being
bombarded with fear-mongering and
right-wing propaganda 24 7 for over two
decades
time can do a lot to normalize things
and many older people have simply
accepted fox news as a valid alternate
perspective on reality
when its explicit goal from the very
beginning was to act as a propaganda
outlet
but time wasn't the only culprit in
turning millions of patriotic americans
into spiteful nationalists
after 9 11 fox news ramped up its
pro-america anti-foreigner rhetoric
feeding on the fear and uncertainty of
this new era suddenly all brown people
were suspected terrorists and of course
we had to invade iraq to bring them
freedom and democracy
even after it became common knowledge
that we had started a war under false
pretenses
fox news and the new wave of
conservative radio talk shows kept
feeding their audience bad information
smearing the middle east as a primitive
hellhole europe as do-nothing socialists
and south america as full of failed
states
the united states was the last bastion
of truth and freedom in the world
of course these propagandists including
other news networks
left out some key details like the fact
that the us had destabilized the middle
east for generations
killed innocent civilians including
school children and people at a wedding
and captured and illegally tortured
people in secret prisons
and that's just in the middle east
american media will never report on the
dozens of coups we've orchestrated in
latin america
overthrowing democratically elected
governments and installing dictators
like pinochet
fox may be the most obvious example but
news networks from cnn to abc to cbs
all play a critical role in maintaining
the myth that america is the greatest
freest nation on earth since 2001 there
has been a huge shift away from passive
patriotism to active nationalism
but where news networks excel in putting
out a polished seemingly factual message
they lack one critical thing the
personal connection
some talking heads get pretty close
tucker carlson has the i'm just like you
act down to a science
despite the fact that he makes 6 million
dollars a year to parrot gop talking
points
most news networks are big productions
lots of people flashy graphics
very visual driven and they can't travel
with you on your commute
talk radio host can glenn beck rush
limbaugh bill o'reilly
mark levin newt gingrich all one time
fox personalities who for whatever
reason
whether sexual assault or becoming too
radical even for fox news have had to
leave and start their own one man shows
on streaming radio
can go wherever you go they can talk to
you in your car on the way to work
or to get groceries or to pick up little
tinsley from ballet
it's just you and them one on one no
chirons no breaking news alerts no
boring weather updates
just you the host and pure uninterrupted
ideology
when you consume content around other
people it's just entertainment or
background noise
but when you're alone with the host it
becomes almost like a friendship
you feel like you know the person like
they're a trusted advisor
the more you listen the more their
ideology melds with your own
when there are no voices of dissent or
alternate opinions you begin to accept
everything they say
as fact and that is very damaging for
older people
this is the equivalent of the youtube
fascism pipeline on youtube a young
person will watch a video by joe rogan
then will get recommended one by stephen
crowder then ben shapiro
and then suddenly their homepage is full
of the most baseless toxic far-right
content imaginable
for older people it was watching news in
the evening then fox news debuted and
caught their attention
then the network got more radical and
added extremist primetime hosts
then some of those hosts broke with the
network and started their own shows
and now that extreme content is
available whenever they need their fix
of fear and anger
this is where we start to see the
metamorphosis from nationalist to
fascist
traditional media gives you the shot
fear of other countries
followed by the chaser american
exceptionalist nonsense
talk show hosts take it one step further
and make you hate the people you fear
muslims black people gay people cultural
marxists or
elites which is often code for jews
antifa
immigrants these subgroups are not only
bad they're actively working to
dismantle america and steal your freedom
they'll often use tactics such as one i
like to call schrodinger's immigrant
where immigrants are simultaneously cast
as both lazy welfare recipients and
hyper-productive job stealers
or antifa are described as both whiny
snowflakes and terrorist super soldiers
this double speak is present in all
instances of fascism throughout history
you have to make your people hate the
enemy for their perceived moral failings
but also fear them but while talk shows
are an integral part in the patriotism
to fascism pipeline
they're still missing the final piece of
the puzzle and that's a figurehead that
functions as a cult of personality
i'm going to say a couple of things that
some of you might disagree with
first every president in modern history
has wielded fascist power abroad
trump is not the first one to do it
second i don't think that trump has
always had fascist tendencies
he's very thin-skinned and seems to have
exceptionally malleable opinions
he's been molded by his base just as he
has whipped them into a nationalist
frenzy
they feed on each other in a vicious
ever worsening feedback loop
to the point where now the same people
who fly don't tread on me flags are
calling for the police to conduct mass
arrests on peaceful protesters and
political dissidents
they're supposedly against
authoritarianism but they're calling for
the government to use authoritarian
measures to achieve their xenophobic
goals
they celebrate the police using
excessive force completely oblivious to
the fact that what they're applauding is
in direct conflict with what they claim
to oppose
oppressive government when people move
from loving america over all
others to hating all others because
they're not america to wanting to remove
anything that doesn't comply with their
warped sense of what america represents
they've moved from patriotism to
nationalism all the way to fascism
and they may not have even noticed it
happening so
how do you spot a fascist they typically
hold inconsistent views about violence
and government overreach
they're vocal about the groups they hate
and fear they want a white ethno state
they support donald trump to the point
where they applaud his suggestion of
getting a third term
and they do things like this
[Music]
[Applause]
only in america could someone be so
misguided that they think
dressing up as the statue of liberty a
beacon of welcome to all people
and wearing a make america great again
mask while vandalizing a call for
justice and equality
is what it truly means to be great it's
hard to know how far along your loved
ones are on this spectrum
and it's even harder to watch people you
love turn into hateful shadows of their
former selves
but a conversation could go a long way
towards derailing that process
there are ways to tell if someone you
care about has fallen into this pipeline
if they consume content that makes them
feel attacked or marginalized by a
different ethnic group
sexual orientation or other immutable
characteristics of other people
if those voices are calling for war or
for the jailing of citizens for holding
dissenting opinions
if those networks or personalities sell
shady products like brain pills or
useless powders
it's probably time to say something
there's no guarantee you can drag your
loved ones back from this toxic
whirlpool of propaganda and
fear-mongering but it's worth a shot
every time fascism has arisen around the
world the people later reported thinking
it can't happen here but it can happen
and it is
as i expected would happen this video
was instantly demonetized
it's an incredibly important topic but
since advertisers don't want to touch it
youtube won't recommend this video
that's why i've decided to make the rest
of the series exclusive to rockfin
rockfin is a new platform for monetizing
content that would be suppressed on
sites like youtube
i want to keep making videos on timely
and important topics like this one
but i also need to make a living and i
can't do that if youtube keeps
demonetizing my content
if you've been thinking about becoming a
patron consider trying rockfin instead
you'll get access to all my political
videos
including my exclusive series on the
resurgence of fascism but you'll also
get access to other great radical
creators like richard medhurst and nico
house and their exclusive content
so really it's like patreon except it
supports not just me
but also other leftist channels like
mine you can make a rockfin account
completely free
and get access to all the free content
on the platform but if you really want
to help support me
and other channels like mine consider
signing up for a paid membership
it's 10 bucks a month which is like two
coffees and it really does help me pay
the bills and keep producing the radical
content that needs to be made
follow the link below to give rockfin a
shot and you'll be helping me produce
content to radicalize the next
generation of organizers who will help
us build a brighter future for all of us
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week